with Dance Moms coming back for season 8
it's time to take a look back at some of
the most controversial dances over the
years can you guess which stances are
the most controversial in our opinion
let us know in the comments below or
just keep watching to find out if you
were right electricity season one of
Dance Moms is only a small glimpse into
controversies that this show has had but
it definitely gives us a good insight
into the world of competitive kid
dancers we're introduced to a bunch of
things but episode 2 introduces us to
the first controversy let's just say no
one was ready to see these adorable kids
in costumes like these electricity is
one of Dance Moms most memorable dances
for all the wrong reasons it's also
among Abby Lee Miller's top ten dances
as stated by the 20th episode of season
4 electricity comes with all sorts of
controversy not only did Christi give a
hilariously inappropriate name to the
kids costume the entire dance was also
branded as inappropriate even the
episode is called wildly inappropriate
during the dance you can see everyone
shocked expressions Holly even said that
this is the dance she wouldn't want
anyone to see her daughter perform it's
also the dance that got Dance Moms
banned from the Starbound competition
according to reports the editing was
misleading which includes having altered
competition results the dance didn't end
up winning at the competition but that
doesn't mean it didn't show that the
girls were really good performers
however it's safe to say that this is
very very inappropriate dance for kids
too hot to handle season 3 saw a
newcomer to the dance team Asia was
already known in the dance world at the
time as a little firecracker and she
came to fire up the team but many have
branded Asia's dances a bit
inappropriate for her age
while she's definitely too hot to handle
when it comes to her energy and
performance people thought a dance like
hers was highly inappropriate and not
only that because Asia's full of sass
and attitude during her performances the
dance really looked way more mature than
it could have been if you compared a
jazz dances to the adorable dances
Mackenzie did you'll see a huge
difference during that same episode
Mackenzie had a solo called Old West and
compared to Asia
it was definitely different if you
didn't know Asia before Dance Moms her
solo was definitely shocking but what
Abby was more shocked about apparently
was the lip-syncing which according to
her is distracting for the judges either
way you just slayed this performance and
showed that she's a force to be reckoned
with and if you followed her dance
journey you know she was just as sassy
outside of Dance Moms so Asia might just
really be too hot to handle
maybe Abby just took that a bit too
seriously with this routine it's
contemporary it's mature and it is very
dark where have all the children gone
Abby was known for her out there
choreography that's more than just
throwing in random moves it was all
about telling a story even though that
story was often controversial it is
called where have all the children gone
where have all the children gone is one
of those routines that sends chills down
your spine
it was featured in season 1 episode 6
called dying to dance
Abby rates this dance as her favorite
dance from the first three seasons and
it truly is one of the most chilling
dances ever
many have said that this routine is one
of the scariest they've ever seen it's a
routine about children who have gone
missing the choreography shows the kids
going missing in many different ways but
not only is the choreography slightly
disturbing the actual soundtrack used is
chilling too although controversial the
dance was still iconic as it was later
repeated with the mini team but just
imagine being in that room when suddenly
a man starts whispering about children
disappearing at the same time you watch
the kids disappear onstage it's truly
one of Abby's best dances but at the
same time extremely controversial just
watching the whole dance gives us chills
once again and we're adults we can't
imagine what those kids were feeling as
the music started to play that evil
conniving purse winging troll is going
to be there this weekend I want to send
her home crying that's what she deserves
rock that let's be honest Asia has had
plenty of eyebrow-raising choreography
that made us question just how
appropriate they actually were the girl
always managed to deliver not only face
but also energy rock that solo from the
episode called watch your back neck
which is her very first episode on the
show Asia was meant to motivate
Mackenzie and somewhat intimidate her
with her rock and energy but her rock
that solo was definitely the one that
was marked as inappropriate just look at
the comments under lifetimes video for
this solo people also pointed out that
the way the routine was edited made them
very uncomfortable the video cuts to her
mom in the audience several times but it
seems to be more focused on a candy
apples member
and people had a lot to say about his
facial expressions Asia definitely
proved that she's a true performer but
the lyrics combined with the
choreography made the whole thing just a
little bit inappropriate it just feels
wrong for a little girl to dance to a
song like that but he just still placed
number one and was crowned Miss petite
energy which is of course true so in the
end she really did rock that after all
hurt them first hurt them first is a
group dance from season 2 episode 13
called Abby gettin this group dance was
inspired by Chicago musicals cell block
tango and if you're familiar with this
song you know that cell block tango was
all about women being in jail during the
dance Holly even said that she can't
even imagine her daughter being in jail
so she can't support this dance Abby
herself said that this group dance
covers a serious and dark topic apart
from the actual jail theme the
choreography and the music itself were a
bit mature for a kid competition maybe
that's why the group placed 10th instead
of getting their usual first or second
place
[Music]
this episode itself is also quite
controversial due to the fact it's
Maddie's first time she's ever forgotten
a solo it was a stressful time so doing
a controversial routine like this was
definitely risky overall it just seems
like this dance pressured the girls to
step out of the box and by the looks of
it they weren't even comfortable with it
even though they slayed the routine
[Music]
Chloe did end up saying that you just
have to put the jail team aside and
focus on the dance itself not to mention
that the title of the dance hurt them
first is extremely inappropriate
no one should hurt anyone the last text
this was one of the first dances that
caught people's attention although it
was controversial it wasn't
controversial in the same way as
electricity or some of the other
routines during the rehearsals Abby
admitted that the last text is extremely
disturbing and was designed to make the
judges feel something you can find it in
season 2 episode 26 and of course the
episode itself is full of drama but the
last text was one of the most shocking
dances coming from the Abby Lee company
it's all about the girls being in a car
texting and having a good time until
that car crashes each of the girls
passes away and Maddie ends up being the
only one that's alive although the piece
itself here is an important message it's
a bit mature for kids that age
[Music]
however even Cathy from candy apples
agreed that this was an extraordinary
routine and that's something you don't
hear very often the last text is also
Abby's second favorite routine ever
created and although it's controversial
the girls really went all out and proved
they're fantastic actresses after all
when it's time for nationals you have to
go all out right and these girls
definitely prove that they're able to
take on just about any theme there is
bully bully is one of the dances that
went viral outside of the Dance Moms
world it's video has almost 7 million
views in lifetimes official YouTube
channel it's one of the last solos
Mackenzie ever performed on Dance Moms
and the first time she got a hip-hop
solo she had to fight hard to get it -
but considering Mackenzie was still a
teen in this dance it's a little bit
inappropriate
[Music]
many pointed out that the choreography
as well as the costume looked pretty
mature for someone her age and even
though Kenzi totally slayed this dance
and deserved first place people had a
lot to say about the choreography this
snaps in the song also made people think
of Beyonce's partition tune which is way
too mature it wasn't the only time
Kenzie's hip-hop dances were deemed as
inappropriate even after she left Dance
Moms but in the end all that matters is
that Kenzi was able to prove Abby wrong
by winning with this dance it's also one
of her most memorable dances which says
a lot considering she always had to do
the same old acro routines so she really
proved to Abby she's more than just an
acro dancer the girl in the plastic
bubble this dance had us all at the edge
of our seats
it was incredibly risky to do and we
were all just hoping nothing goes wrong
luckily the girls are all pros but you
can't deny that you were holding your
breath as was Jojo because according to
the rehearsal she only had about five
minutes of air left in that bubble and
if you were watching the rehearsals you
know Abby was freaking out when Jojo
almost got stuck take her out and zip
her please the zipper is stuck she
definitely did her job and proved she
was an amazing performer her
choreography even had her do pirouettes
while in the bubble which is amazing
during the rehearsal the bubble zipper
was also stuck which is really scary
this was an incredibly dangerous dance
to do is it really worth putting a child
in danger just to get first place in a
dance JoJo's mom even said that Abby
chose Jojo because the more Jojo talks
the less air she'll have of course Abby
would put Jojo in the bubble with only
five minutes of air the more Jojo talks
the less air she's gonna have and we all
know Abby didn't really like JoJo's loud
mouth and she made that clear several
times on the edge of my seat season six
was an explosive season as everyone
seems to compete for Abby's attention
while Abby fights with the law in this
particular episode Kira didn't bring
Kalani's costume her costume had to be
sewn on at the last minute and Abby said
when you look like her it doesn't really
matter what you wear and so Kalani went
out in her bra and shorts
[Music]
although the girls always had
controversial costumes they always
looked like costumes
no Abby Lee company dancer ever went out
in her underwear
of course Kalani's performance was
perfect as always but everyone just
seemed confused by her outfit it
definitely wasn't a good look but if you
wouldn't have watched the behind the
scenes you'd never know it's not a
costume in the first place so in the end
it all worked out it must have been
completely nerve-racking to have a
costume change at the last minute and it
just shows that these girls are complete
pros and now just take a second and
write down in the comments what you
think our last controversial dance is no
cheating's ready for the answer the last
dance did you guess it right let's be
honest this was the dance that went
viral for all the wrong reasons
the girls have grown up over the years
so they wanted to prove to Abby they can
handle mature routines but maybe this
was a little bit too mature even for
them the last dance was choreographed by
another dance teacher and it really
focused on sensuality the whole point
was to show that they're not little
girls anymore during lyrical the dance
was a challenge for everyone but when
Chloe and Christi reacted back to this
dance they had no idea just how sensual
it looked
Oh chief Christy even told Chloe to
never let her dad see this dance fans
had a lot to say about this dance number
and it's safe to say that it was pretty
out there if you've watched Dance Moms
for all seven seasons this was
definitely the most shocking moment ever
and although controversial it is true
that the girls were growing up but is
this so too mature for teenage dances
along with the controversial dance this
episode was extremely intense as the
choreographer of the dance actually
stormed out in the middle of rehearsals
on top of that the mom fight in this
episode was even more intense than ever
before seriously if you're not a regular
Dance Moms viewer you really need to go
get your fix of this drama and
controversial moments and the last dance
was definitely the most controversial
moment of them all and that's it that's
our take on Dance Moms 10 most
controversial dances of all time what do
you think
did you guess them right or do you have
your own suggestions leave them in the
comments below and let's talk it out
that's it for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the themes for more videos
like this one thanks for watching and
see you next time
[Music]